[Music]
thank you
welcome back to another episode of
what's up Prof
Martin Walter how are you doing no I'm
doing well and you good
we're going to talk about mahanaim
now why would you want to talk about
that I don't know we'll have to look and
see so get let's open whether we would
have prayed
a Heavenly Father
thank you thank you for all these
blessings and all the things that you do
for us and we ask now your Enlightenment
with the Holy Spirit and guide us in
Jesus name amen
we spoke in the last one about
pendulum swing
and where we're heading in the Stream of
time
and it seems to me that the final
confrontation is coming closer and
closer
and so
what is it that we need to be aware of
when we come to this final confrontation
because a final confrontation like that
can create many emotions yeah we're
gonna have fear
and think what am I going to do in a
case like this
you're realizing that the end is coming
near and you ask yourself am I ready
that's it all of these emotions go
through your head most of your emotions
actually begins with fear
because if you have fear and you can't
get it under control then you can have
anger depression you have all these
other things that actually that's why
the Bible actually Jesus tells us don't
fear don't be afraid
so we we titled this one mahanaim and
we'll see in a moment why so it is
actually a little study on how to deal
with the time that we're living in
how to deal with the coming
confrontation
and also how to be prepared for the
coming confrontation
and also who will be involved yes in the
all right so let's see where we're going
let's start with Revelation chapter 12
verse 17. I mean this is a a key word a
key verse when it comes to any of the
events that will take place
and the dragon was Wrath with the woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
a seed which keeps the Commandments of
God and have the testimony of Jesus
Christ
it's a very loaded verse
if we read there in spiritual gifts it
says the woman is the symbol of the
church and the remnant of the church
represents Christians of the last
generation of men living just prior to
the second Advent
the dragon makes war on these for
keeping the Commandments of God Sabbath
and all
and having the testimony of Jesus Christ
which according to the inspired
definition of chapter 19 verse 10 is the
spirit of Prophecy
here then are the causes of the dragon's
Warfare upon the remnant they teach the
observance of the Ten Commandments and
the Revival of the gifts and acknowledge
the gift of Prophecy amongst them this
creates ire he is angry
and he makes War
when the devil got one foot upon the
fourth Commandment and the other upon
the gifts planted in the Christian
church by Jesus Christ then his satanic
Majesty
was filled with revengeful Delight but
when the remnant whom God designs to fit
for translation to heaven without seeing
death ask for the Old Paths where is the
good way and walk therein then the
dragon is wrath and makes war with them
but he's got the whole world under his
control
he's got them Towing the line
keeping false precepts that come out of
the dictates of men and now all of a
sudden people say where are the ancient
paths and start walking in them that
could upset his apple cart right I'm
sure it is it's doing it already all
right
so that's the basis of the Warfare and
are we named to deal with it
let's continue
Spirit of Prophecy volume 1 of all the
blessings which God has bestowed upon
his people the gift of his son accepted
none have been so sacred and so
important to their welfare as the gift
of the Holy his holy law
and His Holy Spirit
the gift of God's son
is incalculable
it is incomputable it will be the study
of all eternity right
but the Hedge that he has put in and the
mechanism whereby we can know which way
to go
is the law
and the guidance of the Holy Spirit
it's amazing what you just said because
a lot of people say ah but the law is a
burden
it's a yoke no it's light and it's a
hedge it's a hedge to protect protect
you
so those two without them you will not
get to your final goal because the Holy
Spirit has to convict you
but he will convict you of sin
righteousness and judgment right he
brings you back to the law and if you if
you take the law out then you don't have
a definition of sin and you don't have a
definition of righteousness yeah then
you can make up your own story and
correct and Jesus was the law embodied
none have been so well calculated to
thwart the plans of Satan and
consequently to stir his rage as these
and when that people should arise in the
last generation of men who should be
observing all ten of the precepts of
God's holy law and should recognize the
Revival of the spirit of Prophecy they
might expect to feel that bitterness
from their opponents
which can arise only from the direct
inspiration of Satan
and the dragon was Wrath with a woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
a seed which keeps the Commandments of
God and have the testimony of Jesus
Christ you know once that fullness sinks
in
and you accept that verse
then you are in a war
that's it automatically
you cannot
accept God in your life
and have it easy no
the testimony of Jesus said the angel to
John is the spirit of Prophecy
Revelation 19 10 it is the keeping of
The Commandments of God and the
recognition of the Revival
of the spirit of Prophecy by the remnant
of the church or the Christians of the
last generation that stirs the ire of
the Dragon
that's one of the reasons why we have
never tried to hide it under a bushel we
put it up front and it creates a stir
but if the star is positive
then people will understand what the
value is that has been added
so that is a very important point that
we need to ponder
so let's sum this up those within the
church that do not hold to the testimony
or that marginalize it cannot thus by
definition be part of the remnant
is that too harsh a thing to say Martin
we've been saying it all along
right don't call yourself
part of the remnant if you don't qualify
for the qualifications needed by the
Bible to be part of the remnant some in
the remnants say all right we keep the
Commandments but the other one we won't
have there are two leagues
two legs
because arraignment must have both
attributes
there are thus members and leaders in
the church that are not part of the
remnant but part of the tears
and unfortunately the Bible tells us
that the wheat and the tears grows
together so those tears are going to
remain in the church until the Harvest
and we often ask ourselves Lord why do
you allow the tears in the church they
they are such a problem well it's
sometimes it seems that they are the
majority as well well they are the
majority there are more tears than there
are
True Believers in both legs
but Martin when the storm comes when the
wind comes
what happens to tears
blows away they just blow away
so I I feel we are heading for a storm
there is a wind coming a whirlwind as a
matter of fact
and how are you going to stand in these
last days because the confrontations
will not only come from without
they will also come from within actually
more from within and the tears will be
very very active
in fact very often we have come across a
tremendous opposition largely because of
the second leg the spirit of Prophecy
yeah
so Martin why have we called this my
name
I don't even know if we pronounced that
correctly but whatever that's what it
says there
well we find it in the Bible and if you
look it up in the concordance what does
it mean
so something like that
it's a double camp
a place in Palestine
it occurs 13 times in the King James
version and it means Two Hosts
so the Lord's host and Jacob's host is
one of the examples
and we do not have to face the enemy
alone because there are two hosts
Ma
IM something like that Martin whatever
just say okay
so we have to look up and see in which
way does this Comfort Us in which the
way does this admonish us and in which
way does it give us
some
surety that we do not have to face this
enemy alone alone exactly
well like you said it gives us some
self-assurance and some peace to know
you're not battling this alone you're
not alone
so let's just look at this story and get
the context Genesis chapter 32.
and Jacob went on his way and the angels
of God met him now that's plural modern
yeah angels of God met him
and when Jacob saw them he said this is
God's host
and he called the name of that place
so there was his house the people that
were with him
and then there was God's host
and Jacob sent messages before him to
Esau his brother unto the land of Sir
the country of Edom
so he was on his way to meet his brother
and he realized it was going to be a
very dangerous operation
because Esau had promised to kill him
yeah yes
now Issa was his brother
that makes you think doesn't it it does
there are related yes so
in a church format
it can be they are from the same Faith
probably it could be but the one tried
to do what the Lord wanted him he made
mistakes big mistakes but he tried to do
what the Lord wanted them to do
and he felt sorrow for his sin
but the other one was a religion of
compromise
and just the very ones that he
surrounded himself with Esau he took his
wives not from the children of Israel he
took his wives outside of that milieu
and the mindset of Esau the Bible says
God hated yeah it says Esau he hated but
God doesn't hate anyone he wants to save
everyone
and we can see at the end of time that
even the many of them will be
saved
so it's not about that it's about the
mindset yes that's what the AIDS the
same with Cain
so what was the mindset of eso wasn't it
a mindset of compromise of mingling
wasn't it an economical mindset
basically it was it was about rebelling
as well
yes
Genesis 32 verse 4 and he commanded them
saying thus shalty speak unto my Lord
Esau thy servant Jacob says thus
I have sojourned with Laban and stayed
there until now and I have oxen and
acids and flocks and Men servants and
women servants and I have sent to tell
my Lord
that I may find find Grace in his sight
so it's very courteous
but he is very apprehensive
and The Messengers returned to Jacob
saying we came to thy brother Esau and
also he cometh to meet thee and 400 men
with them
these were probably armed to the teeth
right yeah that's actually an army all
right so here is a clash of armies
but it's interesting that Jacob knew
that he was not alone there were two
troops
he wasn't going to be able in his
strength to overcome his soul no
then Jacob was greatly afraid and
distressed and he divided the people
that was with him and the flocks and the
herds and the camels into two bands
and he said if Esau came to the one
company and smite it then the other
company which is left shall Escape
so even here there were two bands within
within Jacob they were two bands yeah he
probably did not
he also distinguished which ones to put
at a certain place yes
and Jacob said oh god of My Father
Abraham and God of my father Isaac the
Lord which said unto me return unto thy
country and thy Kindred and I will deal
well with thee so was he doing this
under a specific command of God yes yes
therefore he could have relied on the
responsibility that was also God's
response that's it when God promises
something or gives you something to do
then there's obviously you can rely on
him supplying you the means to do it all
right now how does that apply to us when
we have to go and face this enemy in the
time that we are living in
and he he acknowledges that he's not
worthy I am not worthy of the least of
all the Mercies
and of all the truth which thou shout
unto thy servant for with my staff I
passed over this Jordan and now I'm
become two bands
so even within God's people there are
divisions
as we Face the enemy there are divisions
and we are going to have divisions in
our ranks and some will actually turn
against God's people yes and join the
other side deliver me I pray thee from
the hand of my brother from the hand of
Esau for I fear Him lest he will come
and smite me and the mother with the
children
and thou says thy will surely do the
good and make thy seed as the sand of
the sea which cannot be numbered for
multitude so he's rehearsing his
experience with God yeah and the
promises
and he lodged there that same night and
took of that which came to his hand to
present for Esau his brother 200 she
goats 20 he goes 200 U's 20 Rams 30 milk
camels interesting it's like the old
English
German milk camels with their cult 40
kind 10 Bulls 20 she asses ten Falls
and he delivered them into the hand of
his servants every drove by themselves
and set them unto his servants pass over
before me
and put a space
betwixtrove and drove
so he's doing everything in his power to
show that he is not an enemy but that he
has the well-being of his brother at
heart
that's
so when we bring the gospel
is it to only slam or is it for the
well-being and to convert so important
always
it must be that you want to
evangelize you want to help
whenever you do anything
and he commanded the foremost saying
when Esau my brother metatheon asked us
these saying whose Art Thou
and with a goeth thou and whose are
these before thee then shalt thou say
they be thy servant Jacobs it is a
presence sent unto my Lord Esau and
behold also he is behind us
and so commanded he the second and the
third and all that followed the drove
saying in this manner shall you speak
unto Esau when you find him
and say ye moreover Behold thy servant
Jacob is behind us for he said I will
appease him with the present that goes
before me
and afterward I will see his face per
Adventure he will accept me
so when the present over before him and
himself lodged that night in the company
he did everything possible to show that
he was not malicious
and that he had good intentions
and we must do the same right
but then comes the night of wrestling
because he knows that this enemy
will kill him
if God does not intervene yeah he cannot
with his host face it alone no and we're
going to have the same experience we're
going to face this house that is hostile
thinking that we are on a war path with
him when actually actual fact our motive
is to win them over to God's cause
and they perceive the motive as one of
hate speech and aggression yes they
think we are attacking and the mean and
if you are you must change how you feel
about it because it has to be like you
said to win them over it must be of Love
of help
and then he goes through what is called
the Knight of Jacob's trouble
and that is something that we will have
to go through it's prophesied that God's
people will go through a night of
Jacob's trouble wrestling with yourself
because if you are not right with God
how are you going to face the enemy
and he rose up that night and took his
two wives and his two women servants and
his 11 sons and passed over the Ford
yabak
and he took them and sent them over the
brook and sent over that he had and
Jacob was left alone
and there Wrestled a man with him until
the breaking of the day so Martin this
is not something you can do in a group
this is a personal issue something
between you
and God
and when he saw that he prevailed not
against him
this is now Jesus wrestling with Jacob
God himself he touched the hollow of his
thigh and the hollow of Jacob's thigh
was out of joint and he wrestled with
him
and I was even incapacitated to it
a sense in a sense right so he realized
that he had no defense
his entire defense was God now that's it
that's it
he relies now on the other troop he's
actually just a vessel now yes just
relying on the and he's limping yeah do
you think we're limping mod yes I think
we're so bastard and not only the
episode creeping everything's out of
joint
and he said let me go for the
daybreakerth and he said I will not let
thee go except thou bless me that must
be
our Battle Cry
I will not let thee go
do you think the devil is throwing the
book at us to make us let go oh yes make
us lose confidence in God every trick
you can throw at us he's trying surely
you haven't come across this have you
[Laughter]
no I definitely have yeah okay and he
said unto him what is thy name
and he said Jacob
and he said thy name shall be called No
More Jacob but Israel for as a prince
thou has power with God and with men and
has prevailed
we will all if we are faithful receive a
name change right a new name a new name
and it says there has power with God
and Jacob asked him and said tell me I
pray thee thy name and he said wherefore
is it that thou does ask of the my name
and he blessed him then
and Jacob called the name of the place
peniel for I have seen God face to face
and my life is preserved
so he didn't actually get the name
he had to be satisfied with the
knowledge that God cares that's it he
had to have faith yes
and as he passed over penuel the sun
rose upon him and he halted upon his
thigh
so Martin we're going to halt on our
thigh as we Face the anti-typical Esau
therefore the children of Israel eat not
of the sinew with strength which is upon
the hollow of the thigh and to this day
because he touched the hollow of Jacob's
thigh
and the sinew that shrank
so Martin if we jump to the New
Testament and we absorb the issues of
the story the night of wrestling he
would not let go he was a sinful man
Jacob
he had deceived in the way in which he
got the birthright initially he he
bought the birthright for a bowl of
lentil stew
but then to make sure that he really got
it he deceived yes and that was a sin
and he repented of that sin and God
forgave him
so if we jump to the New Testament and
we read in Romans what our situation
will be we see what shall we say then to
these things
if God before us who can be against us
there are two troops we must never lose
sight of the fact that there are two
truths well it also lets me think of
that situation where the Prophet asked
gazi's eyes to be opened by the by God
and he could see those yes and he saw
the host and it said the Chariots of
Fire they were all around
he that spared not his own son but
delivered him up for us all how shall he
not with him also freely give us all
things
who shall lay anything to the charge of
God's elect
it is God that justifies
who is he that condemneth it is Christ
that died rather yay rather that is
risen again who is even at the right
hand of God who also makes intercession
for us who shall separate us from the
love of Christ shall tribulation or
distress or persecution or famine or
nakedness or Peril or sword
as it is written for thy sake we are
killed all day long we are counted as
sheep to the slaughter now in all these
things we are more than conquerors
through him that loved us for I am
persuaded that neither death nor life
nor angels nor principalities nor powers
nor things present nor things to come no
height no depth nor any other creature
shall be able to separate us from the
love of God
which is in Christ Jesus our lord
this should be our comfort
this is what you go to war with
and no matter how Bleak it looks no
matter how much tribulation these how
much distress how much persecution how
much famine nakedness Peril sword no
matter what he throws at you
this is your comfort that's it God has a
host and he's there he's there my name
there are two hosts
so let's unpack this a little bit let us
love God supremely allowing no influence
to come between us and our God we must
give heed to the light which God has
permitted to shine upon our pathway
we must show before all Heaven that we
appreciate every ray of light we must
reflect that light upon others
that's important right it's not a
self-centered love no we don't have a
self-centered religion
but we must also appreciate the light
that God has given how do you show that
you appreciate light that God has given
when you share it and when you act upon
it yes when it shines so you share it
and you act upon it you can't share
light that you don't live yourself
exactly if you don't let's take it in a
practical if you don't read your Bible
you cannot not have the light to shine
that's right and if you don't apply it
to your life you're a hypocrite
we are responsible to God for our
influence even if we are compelled to
stand apparently alone we are not alone
for Christ is with us to encourage and
strengthen and bless us is acquainted
with every desire of your heart
with every purpose of your soul he says
I will not leave you comfortless I will
come to you John 14 18. let us believe
that God will do just as he has promised
we must not allow our minds to drift and
come to no point
we know that the Lord is soon to come
and we must serve God from principle and
be firm as a rock to follow in the path
of obedience because it is it is the
only safe path
all right so is there something that we
have to do yes we have to be obedient
and we have to live up to the light that
we have
and when we do that then we must also
share it yes
will that Inspire the Wrath of the of
the Dragon we have a promise that it
would yes okay
so we're looking at how to deal with
with the last conflict
and we must have this word in our mind
we're not alone we're not alone even if
it looks as if we are alone even if
we're limping
how are we going to do this how are we
going to fight a Nimble
enemy if I'm limping on one hip
his servants are as dear to him as the
apple of the eye in trial in one in
perplexity and distress we are not alone
at every step in tones of assurance he
bids us follow me
I will never leave nor forsake thee but
this Blessed Assurance is given only on
condition of our obedience and
faithfulness to him
people don't like those words they want
to make it
legalistic if you say if you call
obedience they like the first part yeah
but they don't like the second part
to Peter the words follow me were full
of instruction
not only for his death but for every
step of his life was the lesson given
the hitherto Peter had been inclined to
act independently
so how important is it that the hippie
out of joint
utterly important okay because otherwise
you're gonna lean on yourself okay
he had tried to plan for the work of God
instead of waiting to follow out God's
plan
but he could gain Nothing by rushing on
before the Lord Jesus bids him follow me
do not run ahead of me then you will
have the hosts of Satan to meet alone
let me go before you and you will not be
overcome by the enemy
it's beautiful beautiful
those who preach the truth will meet
Satan in many forms
it is the duty of the minister of Christ
to stand faithful at his post in the
fear of God
thus he may put to confusion the hosts
of Satan and Triumph In The Name Of The
Lord
so standing at your post
you overcome the devil
doing your duty doing your duty yeah
being obedient
all right here's a very interesting
quote from Jesus name above all name
page 150.
God will again move mightily upon chosen
servants to make terrible charges upon
the hosts of Satan
is that attack mode modern that is often
offense that's offense right so yeah you
don't stand and wait for it to defend
you are going over to the offensive side
the people whom you will accept to carry
forward his work to fight his battles
must be people of principle
Brave firm and true
Customs traditions and doctrines even of
the professely great and good people
must have no weight
until first brought to the infallible
test of the law and the testimony and we
go back to
Revelation chapter 12 verse 17.
to the law unto the testimony
as I already said it if they speak not
according to this word there is no light
in them so we cannot listen to what
anybody says unless we've put it through
the filter of the law and the testimony
Martin
what have you become confused on the law
and you're thinking you're keeping the
law in actual fact you're keeping
another law that has been modified to
look like God's law
and you might not even know it you not
read the testimony
that's the problem there's also a verse
that says my people are dying for a lack
of knowledge correct
so if they speak not according this word
it is because there is no light in them
to this test popes and prelates refuse
to submit knowing that it would
overthrow it once all their pretended
power
it was to maintain this great truth that
Luther battled so firmly and fearlessly
his words echoed down the line to all
the tried and tempted Defenders of the
truth Stand Fast
in the Lord Jehovah is Everlasting
strength
so this battle has been fought many many
times but the final battle
will be on a universal scale
and nobody is excluded because the
kingdom of God has penetrated all
kingdoms put itself above them and
people are pressing in right exactly so
you see and still
it cannot be fought alone this whole
battle will be along with the host
that's why we have to remember the word
manohim we're not alone
so the nature of the final battle
the Lord has opened his Armory and has
brought forth the weapons of his
indignation so who's doing the fighting
God is God is
at his own world God summons the forces
of nature
to overthrow the might of his enemies
fire hail snow Vapor stormy wind
fulfilling his word
quoting Psalms 148 verse 8. when the
Heathen amorites had set themselves to
resist his purpose God interposed
casting down great stones from Heaven
upon the enemies of Israel we are told
of a greater battle to take place in the
closing scenes of Earth's history
when Jehovah has opened his Armory and
has brought forth the weapons of his
indignation quoting Jeremiah
hast thou inquired entered into the
Treasures of the snow or hast thou seen
the treasures of hail which I have
reserved against the time of trouble
in the day of battle and War Job 38 22
and 23 it's a battle in its War
and there will be physical War probably
as well yes
the Revelator describes the destruction
that is to take place when the great
voice of the Temple of Heaven announces
it is done
he says they fell upon men a great hail
Out of Heaven every stone about the
weight of a talent
so this will be a mighty conflict
you see so this was more the scenes in
that time of trouble when the plagues
are falling yes this is the final battle
this is Armageddon but before this and
that's the Lord fighting now that's his
host actually that's him fighting but
before that you've got this spiritual
battle as well that also he has to be
part of yes and the and the weapons of
our Warfare we have to look at that
do we take the sword out we'll have to
be very circumspect when it comes to
that so in the last scenes of this Earth
history war will rage that's a physical
wall that will be raging amongst the
Nations
we're not to be involved in that war no
we have a different War
the powers of evil will not yield up the
conflict without the struggle but
Providence has part to act in the battle
of Armageddon
the captain of the Lord's host will
stand at the head of the angels of
heaven to direct the battle he on Whose
vesture is written the name king of
kings and Lord of lords leads forth the
armies of Heaven on white horses clothed
in fine linen and clean and white this
is a righteous battle that's it like you
showed us in the Armageddon what's a
prostituted two years probably ago
this will be at the second coming we are
part of this battle
we are part of it spiritually we are
involved physically because there will
be consequences to the choices that you
make
and the final Conflict will be short but
terrible we know these quotes but let's
read them again
we are standing on the threshold of
great and solemn events Prophecies of
fulfilling
the last great conflict will be short
but terrible I'm very glad that it will
be short yes but it's coming
it's just around the corner
old controversies will be revived
new controversies will arise we've seen
some new ones
are you going to be with a work crowd or
are you not going to be with it
we have a great work to do our
ministerial work must not cease now
we're getting to some practical advice
what must we do in the time that we are
living in
the last warning must be given to the
world okay that's number one number one
we can't sit back and say let's just
preach the love of Jesus
you have to go in the offense you have
to go to the offense and who will be in
that offense we've seen already but
we'll see some more
so the world must hear the message there
is a special power in the presentation
of the truth at the present time how
long will it last only a little while
short time
but every resource we have must go into
this battle now
the inquiry of everyone should be what
am I to whom do I owe Allegiance is my
heart renewed that's Jacob's trouble
right
is my soul reformed are my sins forgiven
will they be blotted out when the time
of refreshing shall come Jacob's trouble
we're all going to have to go through it
that part is my soul reformed
that's a very important thing do I allow
God to change my habits my thought
pattern
My Lifestyle my lifestyle
you know we have been so indoctrinated
with the concepts of the world
I have come across so many people who
who believe once saved always saved
and are there no consequences to
transgression
prophets wrote for their own and our day
the last books of the Old Testament
shows us workers taken from the laborers
in the fields others were men of high
ability and extensive learning but the
lord gave them visions and messages
these men of the Old Testament spoke of
things transpiring in their day and
Daniel asiah and Ezekiel not only spoke
of things that concerned them as present
truth but their sights reached down to
the Future and to what should occur in
these last days
well if you can just quickly bring that
back to that episode we did on Last Days
End of Time and all of those
it shows you once again
they Daniel and them actually foresaw in
that whole era of Christianity and the
remnant part yes what All the Troubles
will be and categorize so neatly for us
and and still we mix it all together
like in a blender
so Christ stands by the side of
persecuted Saints never is the Tempest
right soul more dearly loved by a savior
than when he is suffering reproach for
the truth's sake when for the truth's
sake the believer stands at the bar of
unrighteous tribunals Christ stands by
his side
all the reproaches that fall upon the
human believer fall upon Christ in the
person of his Saints I will love him
said Christ and will manifest myself to
him
quoting John chapter 14.
trust is condemned over again in the
person of his believing disciples when
for the truth sake
the believer is incarcerated in Prison
Walls Christ manifests himself to him
and ravishes his heart with his love
when he suffers death for the sake of
Christ Christ says to him they may kill
the body but they cannot hurt the soul
we have good chair I've overcome the
world Martin do we have that faith we
have to get it if we don't and
this is hard words
this is talking about physical
maybe torture death going through rough
things but
if those things should happen God Will
Supply the strength to deal with it he
will give you the gift of martyrdom
as he gave those Martyrs that but we
have a promise that there will be many
that will be translated message
otherwise Elijah
would not have been a representative of
those that will overcome without seeing
death so I think if we put our Focus
towards this end
we must focus on the job being done and
not oh what's going to happen to me
correct it says they crucified me and if
they put you to death they crucify me
afreshing the person of my Saints
persecution cannot do more than cause
death
but the life is preserved to eternal
life and Glory the persecuting power may
take its stand and command the Disciples
of Christ to deny the faith to give heed
to seducing spirits and doctrines of
devils by making void the law of God
but the disciples may ask
why should I do this I love Jesus
I will never deny his name when the
power says I will call you a disturber
of the peace they may answer thus they
call Jesus who was truth and Grace and
peace
now we've got all of these things
and we're heading for this time and we
need to be fortified
but we have a promise too that God will
not allow you to be challenged and
tempted beyond what you can endure
so with every trial he gives an outcome
as well and that main thing is what
you've though
discussion is going about him he is
there with you all right now let's just
have a look who's going to be involved
God's measurement of those who walk in
the light they have
the Lord will give his message to those
who have walked in accordance with the
light that they have had that's an
important point someone if you had only
a little bit of light
God will give you his message and you
have to walk according to that light
and will recognize them as true and
faithful according to the measurement of
God these men will take the place of
those
who having light and knowledge have
walked not in the way of the Lord but in
the imagination of their unsanctified
hearts but it's not good enough to say
I'm part of this church that has great
light
if you don't live according to the light
God will rather choose someone who has a
little bit of light but has lived up to
it that's it and it's scary that's a big
problem that we have because we all have
imagination
oh but I'm okay I'm doing this and this
and this but that part that God has
shown me I'm putting it off I'll work on
that later we are now living in the last
days when the truth must be spoken
when in reproof and warnings it must be
given to the world irrespective of
consequences Martin we cannot have a
wishy-washy message
if there are some who will become
offended and turn from the truth
we must bear in mind that there were
those who did the same in Christ's day
must we become discouraged when people
turn from the truth
it is hard but no we must not get
discouraged no matter who that person is
if it be you if it be me it should not
discourage you or me we should just
carry on carry on and still your heart
goes out to the person what did we learn
in the beginning that you have to still
do it with the love with that caring so
if you have to put somebody off or and
say okay I'm not going to be affected by
this it doesn't mean that you write them
off yes now every day somebody well not
every day but almost every day somebody
sends me something
by someone who has become offended and
turned his back on the truth and on the
church and says well what do you say
about this almost like a challenge you
know are you going to stick with this
crowd or what are you going to do
I have to ask myself where is the truth
the fact that there are people that
don't live up to the truth doesn't make
it any less the truth that's it right so
some of these people they are offended
and they say you know in the beginning
it was fine it was the truth but now
there are so many that are not living
the truth therefore I'm not going to do
this and many get offended with the the
testimonies of course and leave the
church because of that
well I have news for them their places
will be taken by those who have had a
little light and lived up to it yeah I I
just want to also say on that note you
were talking about this getting
discouraged well how many
videos
do we get from people that make videos
against well what study that we do
that's fine if they if they come with it
thus says the Lord and so is where we
are wrong that's fine they're just
ranting and raving let them rent and
ride and that's what I said so it's not
necessary to always sit here and defend
ourselves the whole time against those
videos because the studying that's being
done here should
speak for itself
we mainly quote don't we
so the ranks will not be diminished not
no matter how many people Apostle does
even if it be not one in 20 that remains
that's a quote by the way
but there are many who will receive the
truth and these will take the places
made vacant by those who become offended
and leave the truth
the Lord will work so that the
disaffected ones will be separated from
the true and the loyal ones the ranks
will not be diminished those who are
firm and true will close up the
vacancies that are made by those who
become offended and apostatize you know
it's interesting Martin
they all tell you that you must separate
and come out
basically they've separated themselves
already I've mentioned this many times
before if there's a shaking
and those that are shaken out all the
tears that will be blown away or all of
that is outside of it and you are going
on now we have to get out on which side
are you standing and there are so many
Winds of Doctrine but they're barking
from outside now because they've
separated themselves and think you must
separate yourself too and then they come
with the whole they try and put this
together that oh no but the problem is
that which you are still in is not the
true this is now the church this is not
the truth but the the Bible says there
will be a spewing out not a coming up
except out of Babylon that's it
many will prize the wisdom of God above
any Earthly advantage and will obey the
word of God as the Supreme standard
these will be led to great light these
will come to the knowledge of the truth
and will seek to get this light of Truth
before those of the acquaintance
who like themselves or anxious for the
truth
so there will only be two sides you're
either on the side of Christ who are you
on the side of Satan only two armies
we are nearing the clothes of Earth
history when two parties alone can exist
and every man woman and child will be in
one of these armies Now isn't this the
reason why Satan has created so many
apparent armies yeah
exactly to let you and then you can
choose any other one give you a smorgas
born there are only two
to the Lord to the testimony if they
speak not according to this word they
belong to the other Army you know this
is so interesting so where's the gray
area here there's no gray area I wonder
because there's a lot of people that
love to say there's a gray area and they
love to live in that area only two trees
when it came to a moral choice and you
either chose the one or the other there
was no fence to sit on and don't we get
a lot of flack of people that say we see
things only in black and white
and absolutely all the time well if you
see it that way isn't it in harmony with
this only two ways and that's it only
two ways you can't sit on a fence like
Martin Luther said you either stand
behind Christ or you stand behind the
devil or else you're going to get
crushed you're standing on the fence
you're going to get crushed
so Jesus will be the general of one Army
of the Posen Army Satan will be the
leader all who are breaking and teaching
others to break the law of God the
foundation of his government in heaven
and in Earth are marshalled under one
Superior Chief who directs them in
opposition to the government of God
imagine when you watch television and
you watch the Grammys and you watch all
of these uh is it rocket science to
determine whose side they're on
depends on what type of frontal lobe
you're using because if you are
brainwashed with it you don't see it
I mean it's so obvious that they are not
part of it and this is this is the
propaganda of the world that's it
they've taken away logical thinking
completely so if you love the world then
you are in enmity with God right you're
an enemy
all who are breaking and teaching others
to break the law of God the foundation
of his government in heaven and in Earth
are marshaled under one Superior chief
who directs them in opposition to the
government of God now if you want to
know about the government of God you
don't just read the Ten Commandments
read it all
that's you go and read Leviticus
and see where you stand in the Stream of
time compared to what's happening in the
world out there and you will know that
the world is not living in harmony with
God they're living in harmony with the
Devil
and they will show it in the Grammys by
wearing Devil's horns they show it
blatantly
but then people are defending the devil
now yes
and the angels which kept not their
first estate but left their own
habitation or Rebels against the law of
God and enemies to all who love and obey
his Commandments
these subjects which Satan their leader
will gather others into their ranks
through every possible means to
strengthen his forces and urge his
claims
through his deception and delusion Satan
would if possible deceive the very elect
his is no minor deception he will seek
to annoy to Harris to falsify to accuse
to misrepresent all whom he cannot
compel to give him honor and help him in
his work his great success lies in
keeping men's Minds confused
and ignorant of his devices for then he
can lead the unwary as it were
blindfolded
button these are such excellent
statements and then people say this is
false prophecy yeah and why do you want
to continue reading all of these things
now let me just ask
after reading a quote like that can you
see how people want to justify things
always and that's what's bothering me
these days we always want to justify
some reason why I don't have to work on
this or it's not yet necessary or God
knows my heart you try to move to a gray
area that's it
Isaiah 52
now therefore what have I here says the
Lord that my people is taken away for
not
they that rule over them make them to
howl says the Lord and my name
continually every day is blasphemed do
we see that in the world no yes
therefore my people shall know my name
they shall know his character
therefore they shall know in that day
that I am he that does speak behold it
is I
that day that's the final Reckoning how
beautiful upon the mountains or the feet
of him that bringeth good tidings that
publishes peace that bringeth good
tidings of good that publishes salvation
that says unto Zion thy God reigneth in
other words evangelism is beautiful in
the sight of God thy Watchman shall lift
up thy voice with the voice together
they shall sing for they shall see eye
to eye when the Lord shall bring again
Zion but we're at the point when the
Lord is going to bring against Zion and
the chaff will be separated from the
wheat and we have to stand together with
like-minded people this nonsense that
everybody is an island and speaks here
from one little angle has to stop God's
people have to start speaking with one
voice
one Ministry and another Ministry with
the same purpose must stand together we
must preach the Three Angels message in
unison that's it stop throwing stones at
each other the Lord has made bear his
holy arm in the eyes of all the nations
and all the ends of the Earth shall see
the salvation of our god this is a
universal issue
he continues the party the party go out
from then touch not no unclean thing go
ye out of the midst of her be ye clean
that bear the vessels of the Lord for ye
shall not go out with haste nor go by
flight for the Lord will go before you
and the god of Israel will be your rare
wedding
you're not going to do this alone but
there's a condition yes don't mingle
with the profane don't stay on your side
and be that
no unclean thing must they pure I'm
gonna ask it again is the economical
movement going to be your friend it
cannot it's unclean it's going to be
your enemy what are we doing there
Exodus 13 21 and the Lord went before
them by day in a pillar of cloud to lead
them the way
and by night in a pillar of fire fire to
give them light to go by day and night
he took not away the pillar of cloud by
day nor the pillar of Fire by night from
before his people that Maha nahimi will
be there finished and the angel of God
which went before the camp of Israel
removed and went behind them and the
pillar of cloud went before their face
and stood behind them we are not alone
in this battle
as the decree issued by the various
rulers of Christendom against
commandment Keepers let's just stop
right there it's such an important
sentence didn't we just say that is the
economical movement going to help you no
so just read that again it's Christendom
as the decree issued by the various
rulers of Christendom so the decrees
coming from where from Christendom and
the other nations will follow she leads
out but the other nations will follow
doesn't this bring to mind the pendulum
that we've been talking about have I
practiced that over the last decades
ostracizing groups demonizing groups and
then saying those are the evil ones and
the whole world has to fight them or
else that's it and everybody runs toward
that part
as the decree issued by the various
rulers of Christendom against
commandment Keepers shall withdraw the
protection of government
and abandon them to those who desire
their destruction the people of God will
flee from the cities and Villages and
Associate together in companies dwelling
in the most desolate and solitary places
many will find refuge in the strongholds
of the mountains like the Christians of
the Piedmont Valley
that will make the high places of the
earth their sanctuaries and will thank
God for the munition of rocks
but many of all Nations and all classes
high and low rich and poor black and
white will be cast into the most unjust
and cruel bondage
if you can't get out get out now
the Beloved of God pass weary days Bound
in Chains shut in by prison bars
sentenced to be slain
some apparently left to die of Salvation
in dark and loathsome dungeons no human
ear is open to hear their moans no human
hand is ready to lend them help
but they've got a promise they have a
promise
and God if it is done God will give them
light God will take care of them
medical missionary work must leave room
for the ministry of the word
contempt is never to be expressed in
regard to the promulgation of God's word
the third Angel's message must not be
smothered to death we have to do many
things we have to do medical missionary
work not disjointed from must be linked
to the word of God why are so many
institutes trying to please the World by
separating the word
from the health message you cannot do it
no it will not have the blessing of God
and especially our institutions that has
to do with health this is a nightmare we
we have to get back to
the biblical plan we have to get back to
that old time religion
so Martin we are heading for a time of
Jacob's trouble we are heading for a
showdown with the Enemy
there will be a time of trouble such as
never was we have to bring the message
of warning we have to plead with people
we have to use every means that our
disposal the medical missionary work is
going to be part and parcel of the end
time work
and then the Saints left the cities and
Villages Associated together in
companies living in the most solitary
places Angels provided them food and
water
while the wicked was suffering from
hunger and thirst the writings on the
wall that's it this is where it's
heading and this is actually now
past the way you have been looking after
yourself
the leading men of the earth consulted
together with Satan and his angels busy
around them copies of a writing were
scattered in different parts of the land
giving orders that unless the Saints
would yield their distinct faith
give up the Sabbath and observe the
first day of the week the people were
free after a certain time to kill them
that sounds unimaginable
but Martin we are living in a Time
where we are almost in the wild west
where people pick up their guns shoot
people in grocery stores carry on like
they want and if an enemy is once
defined and a Wrath of the people who
stirred up against them if I can mention
if we think about the past three years
and then weren't there in those three
years Whenever there was let's say a
decree that went out and there were
certain people they didn't want to
adhere to that when they ostracized no
they were even demonized yeah and then
they were even called murderers of
people of their friends if they didn't
do adhere to some things it's it was
horrendous what happened it was
absolutely horrendous
so we can expect the same thing we have
to face this but in this trying time the
saints were calm and composed trusting
in God leaning on his promise that a way
of Escape would be made for them the
only safe path
is to the law and to the testimony
and
coercion has never been part of God's
plan
again at a later date referring to the
league contemplated by the reformed
princes he declared that the only
weapons employed in this Warfare should
be the sword of the spirit this refers
to the speech made by the elector of
Saxony in the time of Martin Luther he
was his protector
and he said we cannot in our conscience
approve of the proposed Alliance our
Lord Christ is mighty enough and can
well find ways and means to rescue us
from danger
and bring the thoughts of the ungodly
princes to nothing they were facing a
war in Europe
and they were trying to make alliances
to see how they were going to fight this
battle it's almost like David numbering
the people
and the elector was given so much wisdom
by God and he said the sword of the
spirit is our weapon
Christ is only trying us whether we are
willing to obey his word or no and
whether we hold it for certain truth or
not we would rather die ten times over
than that the gospel should be a cause
of blood or hurt by any Act of ours
it has rather patiently suffer and as
the psalmist says he accounted as sheep
for the slaughter
and instead of avenging or defending
ourselves leave room for God's Wrath the
Cross of Christ must be born
let your highness be without fear we
shall do more by our prayers than all
our enemies by their boastings only let
not your hands be stained with the blood
of your brethren if the emperor requires
us to be given up to his tribunals we
are ready to appear you cannot defend
the faith each one should believe at his
own risk and peril
written in the great controversy we're
facing that same period we will also
have to say
Here We Stand we can do no other exactly
that we will all be faced with it
so let's bring this to a conclusion
here's another quote let men leave room
for the working of the Lord
let the Lord have an opportunity to take
care of his sacred work to fashion and
to mold it according to his will
the ark was trusted to the kind
and the Lord directed these kind in such
a way that they left their calves behind
them devoting themselves holy to the
work of the Lord directed them to
perform they delivered the ark to the
place where it belonged
but when God's people who should have
known better tried to direct the path
there was a Calamity and a lot of
introspection took place
so let us remember we are in a war
we have a message to bring
the battle is not ours we have to take
the message to the world we cannot not
bring the message we have to apply what
we know we have to live what we know
and then when we have done all of that
we can conclude with Romans 8 verse 38
and 39.
for I am persuaded that neither death
nor life nor angels nor principalities
nor powers nor things present nor things
to come
no height nor depth nor any other
creature shall be able to separate us
from the love of God which is in Christ
Jesus our lord
Martin I think that concludes the matter
we are not going towards any of this
alone my name
two troops let's pray
Heavenly Father
we are living in such perilous times
and a little bit of contemplation about
what awaits us
and what our attitude and our thinking
should be
surely it will be in place
for a Time such as this
help us to reflect
help us to correct
and help us to listen in Jesus name amen
amen
[Music]
foreign